a celebration for Martin Luther King who
would have been 94 years old
[Music]
decades after his death his work to get
a vote for all is still not complete in
1965 president Lyndon Johnson signed the
Voting Rights Act thanks to Martin
Luther King The Measure outlawed
discriminatory voting practices
but a recent report found that more than
4 million people were blocked from
voting in last year's midterm elections
a third of those affected were black and
the words of Martin Luther King still
echo through the years
let us march on ballot
[Applause]
Mr James was one of those who lost the
right to vote because of a conviction on
drug charges as a lawyer keita was able
to get through the complicated process
of regaining the right to vote and she
now helps others do the same for some
people it can be an extremely lengthy
battle and you know for some people they
they have given up because it is a
lengthy better or because it is so
convoluted Stephanie frame was sentenced
to seven years imprisonment on a
conspiracy to commit murder charge she's
unable and unwilling to pay the
thousands of dollars in fines to regain
the right to vote and I came home and I
completed that parole without
being a menace to society I feel like at
that point it should automatically be
given back to me just as quickly as it
was taken away it should automatically
um be given back to me an ugly fact
behind the beauty of its capital
Nashville is that the Republican state
of Tennessee has the second largest
number of disenfranchised after Florida
nearly half a million people that's
close to one in eight voters um you have
to start looking at how do we expand the
electorate and by giving 470 000 people
their voting rights back is how you
expand that electorate and again and I
think you know if and when we do that
that will have huge political
implications what the margins here want
is to restore the vote to 10 times that
number more than four million people in
48 states who were prevented from
casting a ballot last year in the wider
political context it's also about the
struggle between those who want to
reduce voting rights and those who want
to increase them it's not just about
Congress it's about who controls the
courts the police stations and the
school boards the U.S has over half a
million elected officials and the demand
In This Crowd on this day is that they
represent all the country's people not
just some of them
Mike Hannah Al Jazeera Washington